so today we will be discussing hopefully
two subjects one subject is the aws vpc
itself and the other one is called the i
am
the vpc itself is for it's a base
basically um
a network capability of
of aws which will allow you to basically
create your own networks within the
cloud and i am which is a identity and
access management is the key
function of aws that allows you to
create different users permissions and
grants different policies to them which
basically translates to something like
active directory if you use windows
um basically it's a it's a it's a it's a
database of users and what users can do
so i would like to start with vpc itself
so let's go
and and start so today we will be
discussing a few things let me just take
my uh highlighting pen so it's easy to
uh see today i'm gonna go for maybe blue
uh so today we'll be discussing virtual
private uh cloud what it is and how do
we use it we were discussing public
private and elastic api addresses
which belong to every single vpc itself
we'll be talking about public and
private subnets we'll be talking about
internet gateways
root tables
not gateways security groups
uh network acls and all as well as at
the end we're gonna use uh ppc best
practices uh when
when do we use specific scenarios and
why
don't worry if you don't understand a
few of those name naming conventions
they will pretty much become a clear how
once we actually run through and we
start explaining every single of them
and and start giving examples from uh
real life
so
um before we actually start i would like
to understand a little bit more about
you guys regarding um
your knowledge in
a networking to some degree do you do
you have any um
knowledge have experience with the
networks um other systems that go into
running or maybe design in the past
so i can give you more accurate examples
as we go along so okay i can see that
one person responded not much which is
fair enough
i know
some people
have done a little bit
uh somebody has experience with cisco
and and juniper which is um
probably one of the most advanced
technologies out there so for you
probably
aws itself uh would be simplification
rather than
adding extra layer for a layer of
complexity
um but majority of the people i can see
that uh don't have much which is
absolutely fine because once you
actually discuss this and give some
stuff nice examples you can understand
the concept and pretty much throughout
the whole
journey with aws you will be using uh
dpc itself it's a it's a base so i would
like to jump straight away and go to the
next slide
so
in uh in in today we're gonna be
discussing um
uh
the whole concept of dpc in in a in a
specific flow we'll be discussing vpc
subnet first then we'll be discussing
sorry ppc root tables then elastic ips
internet gateway
nut
acls security groups
and then we will be jumping straight
into what dvc is
so this is important to understand and
if someone doesn't uh understand the
concept at first please ask the question
because it's actually fundamental to
understand this
and i'll give more examples and try to
explain this in the in the easier way so
uh amazon defines aws dpcs
amazon virtual uh private cloud also
known as amazon vpc enables enables you
to launch amazon web services
resources into virtual um
let me stay with myself i'm just going
to minimize this a little bit
so it's easier for me to see as well
there you go
into virtual network that you
have defined this virtual network
closely resembles a traditional network
that you operate in your own data center
with the benefits of using the scalable
infrastructure of aws
now if i want to explain this in my own
word what bpc is imagine vpc as
a clean
canvas or a clean network that you
you're working with every single
resource that you deploy you always
deploy within the ppc and that means
that dpc itself
it's only available to you it's not
available to outside world unless you
you wanted to which we'll discuss a
little bit later it's basically
a
imagine warehouse
imagine empty warehouse where you can
put all your um
or your stuff
warehouse has all the walls around it
that means that nobody from outside can
access uh the
the warehouse but you can create the
doors to the warehouse where people can
actually access it and we'll be
discussing different methods how to use
it you can store different things you
can launch different things within this
warehouse is basically
a a container
of sorts a network container that
contains all your resources that you
will ever and always deploy within aws
and that's as simple as this
so i would like to jump straight to the
next slide if possible
um
i have a question here from chandra can
we say a bpc is a security boundary for
specific subnets or multiple subnets
dpc is a container that consists of
either one or multiple subnets pretty
much every single subnet you're going to
spin up it will request you to define
which vpc you want to attach this to
so it's basically
a single dbc can hold multiple subnets
for those who
work with the networking a little bit
more which i know there are a few of you
out there you can think uh from
technical terms that vpc is basically a
vlan
that is created on amazon networking
which allows you to
um
oh i i see that my voice is
breaking i do apologize for that um
let me
let me know if it's breaking a bit more
i will try to reconnect that helped last
time a lot so uh please let me know if
you have more technical issues and i'll
be more than happy to resolve that
cool
um so
let's jump straight into the next slide
basically in this slide number six you
can see that you can build your own uh
vpc now vpc itself um
this is aws um as a cloud so that's
basically your account
and on your account you can have
multiple vpcs and the vpc is basically
this square here which which allows you
basically uh sorry
let me just clear this up again the vpc
is exactly this container here
which allows you to have multiple
subnets multiple uh routing tables uh
multiple resources spun up inside that
will allow you to basically interact
with each other and talk to each other
also what's worth mentioning is that the
vpc itself is always allocated to a
region which means you can have a single
vpc in a single region um
it cannot go outside of the region
if you want to have another region
somewhere else you need to create a
brand new vpc with pretty much the same
setup if you want to which we will
discuss a little bit later so the vpc is
the the widest a possible uh resource or
um
container that holds all your resources
and every single
server or database or anything you can
spin
you can think of
so basically that's that's that's the
bbc um let me clear this up
i have a question here um can we bond
um
can we use our own private ips in the
instance um
uh within a dpc or we bound to use cell
nets which will provide uh
which are provided by aws for the bbc
it's a good technical question basically
the dpc itself you'll be able to
allocate a
a subnet uh range so basically ip range
that you can uh deploy multiple subnets
within
and
well i will show you later on how to do
this in the in the demo but the answer
is that you can allocate any ip you want
obviously um
i think that we want to allocate are
basically in the three different
types basically either
10.0
172.00192.0 which are non-public ones
because that's internal uh
obviously networking
and once you've allocated all those
subnets you'll be able then to do
multiple routing in between you'll be
able to do
lots of other things but that's
basically it
um
i have another question from chandra
this time how many vpcs can we have for
each a z for specific customer is it
only one no um
basically you can have as many vpcs as
you want there is also a soft limit that
aws gives you the stock limit is by
default five that you can extend and
really i think the the
the limit is the sky that you you can
have um
each vpc you can have within the same
region you can have multiple regions
it's entirely up to you how you design
your application um
if you have a single system that runs uh
in in the cloud it's it's it's into an
advantage to deploy everything within a
single vpc because it says sync a single
networking so you don't need to do any
uh complex routing between and opening
additional ports anything like this you
can set your stuff within a vpc by using
either knuckles uh some network acls or
you can also use security groups which
we'll be discussing a little bit later
so so that's the answer to your question
don't look at this particular chart that
we have here on the screen as something
that is complex and you have no idea
about the whole point was to discuss
that tpc is
the widest possible
resource that you can allocate and then
within this you can then allocate
multiple other resources it's a basic
key container to hold all your servers
um
i have another question how is this
charge is the number of vpcs or a number
of ports um
basically vpc itself uh
it's free and up until around three
years ago
uh the bbc was not a a default design
when when people were designing and
deploying servers before uh they didn't
have vpcs it was optional all the
servers were pretty much exposed to the
internet um and they were pretty much on
the same layer so there were no tiers
every single server that you basically
spun out uh was on in the same theories
i'm kind of drawing here which means
everything that was pretty much sitting
on the same tier was pretty much exposed
to the internet the only thing that
limiting those um pesky
hackers from accessing your servers uh
was actually security group sitting on
the box itself saying what can access
and what cannot and that was it but the
need for deploying complex systems like
front web servers and an application
service behind and then databases even
behind that uh and current celebrities
or even force them i would say to deploy
uh a new structure that called vpc and
on this from this moment onwards you
were able to deploy multiple vpcs where
you were to define your ip addresses you
could do everything everything that you
can think of
in the traditional data center so you
can allocate static apps if you want uh
however much of the people are using
dynamic range because of how elastic the
cloud is they don't tend to
connect via aps anymore they tend to
actually connect via
dns names which are fully dynamic
because aws cannot guarantee that every
single server that you're gonna spin
will basically be bulletproof obviously
servers uh go down occasionally and then
aws can bring you a new resource but
users will not be on the same ip which
obviously um encourages you to go away
from this old-fashioned mentality of
assigning static ap's to everything and
now it's more dynamic which means a
single very of the server
doesn't actually cause a a fault in a
whole system because nothing is marked
by ap
so that's that's the biggest advantage
so using virtual private clouds
in aws
i have a question straight away as well
uh resources only launched after using
and defining virtual network
uh the answer to the the answer to this
question is yes
you cannot
launch resources if you did not define a
vpc if you didn't create vpc
yourself and you have a brand new
account
aws by default creates
a basically a predefined
vpc itself the pc itself called default
and it has a very basic routine which
we'll be able to see
in the demo later on today and
you will only be able to allocate those
resources to default but if you want to
specify everything the way you want it
to look you need to create your own vpc
you need to create your own uh subnets
routing tables and so on depending on
what and how you want the system to be
accessed and how you want this to be
connected so i hope i answer your
question
so
uh in this diagram uh
of a default vpc
uh the ci dr block
for default vpc is always slash 16
and
that's important if you don't know what
slash 16 is i can explain to you in a
simple way
basically
a
a network imagine address something like
which i can give you the good example
here
okay i'll give you example like this
imagine you have an address of 172.0.0.0
yeah
you can access
if you're interested a little bit more
about the subnets you'll be able to do a
subnet calculator
and in here you'll be able to
you'll be able to
determining different uh types of
networks now i know it's a little bit
complex and i know it can be
overwhelming um
you'll be able to basically access all
of that
uh via the console as well
uh let me just log off and log in here
so stay with me one second i'm gonna be
able to show you this exactly
and what we are talking here about
there you go i'm gonna log into aws
straight away
and i'll be able to show you this in um
in um
services so if we're gonna go to the
service
i like to order this alphabetically
because it actually makes more sense to
me but if you want to group this by
different uh
collect connections of storage and
databases up to you i like looking
alphabetically because i know exactly
what they're for so if you can go to vpc
you will be able to see straight away
uh it's in here
uh pretty much here you can see you have
a one vpc which is a default one
if we're going to click on this
the vpc doesn't have a name because it's
default and you can see that this
particular pc has an ip range
automatically allocated to it s 1
s172.31.0.0
16. what it means that slash 16
means that you can fully utilize
last two octets of this ip range
if you would have let's say slash eight
you would be able to utilize last three
octets
and obviously every single octet or
every single of them can have a value
anywhere from
um
basically 0 all the way to 2
which means if you have
a slash 16 you can have
0.255.25
0.255
and you can have a 1.255
all the way to 2
five
slash
two five
uh five
basically that's lots of ips slash 16.
so
basic idea when you create a vpc is
the vpc itself you give the widest
possible
range you can have the reason for it is
if you don't do that
uh you will run out of ips and the
networks that you design later on so
so-called subnets you basically
be constricting yourself to a very very
small um
ranges which doesn't actually help so by
default abs came up with a
a pretty much range
that allows you to have a really huge
amounts of ips
and that's just a vpc
once the vpc is created you can't really
change it you have to create a new one
and you have to locate all the resources
so that's very important to create
in the good way in the first place
so going back to the presentation if i
make for a second
um
so in this particular case in here you
can see that
vpc is always using star 16 however you
can allocate slash 8 to it which means
you can use last three octets instead of
last two
which means you can have even greater
amount of ips now once you created the
vpc then you'll be able to see that you
can create a subnets in it
and subnets must be part of the network
that you created in the ppc must
actually be within the range of the
network itself you'll be able to create
multiple subnets and all those subnets
can be uh different you can see here the
one subnet is running dot zero dot zero
slash twenty another one is running dot
six and a dot 16.0.20
now they're a little bit different and i
could go even more detail however i'm
not going to do that because the point
of the class is not to understand how
the network why it works is how aws
actually works so if you want to
research more about the networks and how
to uh have appropriate number of ips in
the future i would encourage you to
uh to do a little bit more research
about the networking um and and you'll
understand much much more about this
concept and i would last i would just
like to focus on on on on the on the vpc
itself
so um basically
that's
the uh ip of the vpc you can have
anything you want
uh that's the subnet and that's the
subnet and that's the default ppc that
we have which gives us 65 536 private uh
ip addresses that you can use for any
subnet or any resources underneath and
i'm pretty sure that more than majority
of the times you're ever going to use
because that means that you can
physically have 65 536 servers running
which is quite a lot and i haven't seen
that many actually running um
in in my life in one uh pretty much
network i've seen this again against the
data centers but i haven't seen this in
a in a single network so that's going to
be a pretty pretty big one
i can see one more question here
can easy to instance retain the ap after
reboot
yes
the reboot itself doesn't remove the
previous ap address in our cases within
your one however aws cannot guarantee on
purpose they say this on purpose the the
instance after reboot will remain the
same
99.9 percent of the time it actually
does however it's worth remembering that
if a base for example has any technical
issue with the host that is actually
sitting underneath so basically a
physical server
and
and you reboot the instance it will
reallocate you to some other hardware
and in this case it can allocate you
with a different ip that's it that's
important to remember it doesn't happen
very often uh but it can happen and
that's something you need to bear in
mind
so
uh custom ppc
uh
by default the instance that you launch
into the virtual private cloud can't
communicate with um
with your own network which means if you
have your own network sitting outside
somewhere
outside of the aws
there is no communication
whatsoever all the communication only is
restricted to
resources that are within the vpc itself
and that's very important to remember
that's a default behavior and aws did
this on purpose because they are very
security um focused and they wanted to
make sure that uh no unrestricted access
is granted by default especially when
when we're learning all of this and
they're not going to open everything
just to make it easier hence everything
is locked by default
that's important to remember so
um what you can do you can connect the
vpc to your existing data center by
using either hardware vpn access or you
can efficiently extend your data center
into the cloud um and treat it maybe as
a hybrid environment which means you can
create specific rules and entries that
will allow you to basically uh
buy a vpn connection here that you can
basically take whole vpc and every
single resource that you have
and you can connect it directly with
your uh
with your own network um and by doing so
we'll be using so-called root tables and
also we'll be using a virtual gateway um
and
we will jump into this in a few seconds
and you'll be able to uh basically
understand
what ips we need to use or why do we use
local while we use internet gateways and
i would like to explain this in a few
seconds so let's jump straight into it
now
hardware vpn access
you can connect your vpc to existing
data center by either using a vpn access
so you can extend your data center
into the cloud and create a hybrid
environment exactly what we just
discussed few seconds ago
to do that you'll be able to create a
dedicated vpn connections going in
between
all of your points um you might have
on-prem you might have a data center you
might have offices around the world and
you'll be able to basically create a
connectors that will allow you to
extend the reach of your network into
the aws and treat aws itself as a as a
part of your network rather than
maybe like extension rather than a
separate
um
resource that is available to you you
don't have to do this you know there's
no need sometimes to do this because
maybe your application is purely hosted
on aws and there is no need for that but
material the times you you do want to
extend because the process when you
migrating stuff to the cloud is a
process that quite likely for some time
you will use a hybrid solution which
means that you will have some resources
sitting on your own network no matter
where they are and you'll be slowly
putting more resources in in the aws and
you'll be running a hybrid solution
which will allow you
to to have
systems running in parallel on both ends
and communicate with each other while
using the vpn connection itself
um
let me just
i see
some questions i have
i can see the question
can't we reserve the ips um
yes and no you can uh basically what you
can do is you can go on the host itself
so uh on the os and you can allocate the
instance with an ip basically allocate
this with a
static ap address um and as long as the
static api address is within the range
of not only vpc itself uh but also some
something that you deploy this
in it will be basically persistent you
can do that um however
it's worth remembering that when you're
designing systems on aws you're really
trying to go away from my static ips
because you're trying the whole reason
of being on the aws is because it's
scalable it's it's flexible and it
allows you to allocate more resources
when you need and when you start doing
study kps you will very quickly restrict
yourself uh
to to a
to the point that you cannot really have
static aps in the dynamic environments
and that simply doesn't work
you basically forget about using static
apis and instead of that you can
allocate the house names to to the
servers that are spinning up and every
single time new server comes to live and
it's got automatically generated ap
address you can now get a host name
called i don't know it's a maybe web one
or web or two or whatever else you want
and you you basically refer to this host
as a web or one two or three whatever
you wanted to call it rather than ip so
even in your application you can use
that which means that if the host dies
or gets restarted and it basically comes
to life um on the different hosts
and by any chance it changed the ip
address it doesn't really matter because
you can still allocate the same hostname
to just different ip which means it's
much more flexible and um it's more
dynamic which is the whole point of the
cloud really
so
um
i can see another question from uh uh
gabrielham
um
is this uh also um is there a connect
also a vpn connection it's an actually
very good question direct connect is not
a vpn connection it is a type of the
connection that you would use as well
between the on-prem and data center the
difference between those two is a vpn
connection is a is a basically a it can
be it's a hardware to hardware or
sometimes hardware to software depending
which which route you want to take
encryption and
basically extension of the network what
a direct connect is is basically peering
between um
your data center and aws
on the quickest and least
um
congested route possible that
aws is basically providing which means
you have dedicated uh low latency
connection but it's worth remembering
that the direct connect is not encrypted
which means if you're gonna push any
traffic directly by a direct connect it
is actually going as a plain text unless
you are obviously encrypted on your end
and to the destination um it's gonna be
like that what's worth mentioning as
well is you can actually run a direct
connect and then you can put vpn
connection via
the direct connect which means not only
have a very quick connection but also
you have an encrypted connection
um
that's that's that's important as well
to remember i have another question here
i will quickly try to answer this
one more thinking in on-premise dhp will
assign the aps addresses to the system
which basically is subnet range how
about obs and how systems and get ip
addresses automatically well it's a good
question address itself will
basically run a dhcp server
or
behind the vpc uh you can
basically by default it's enabled which
means
it will allocate ips to every single
server that you spin up within the vpc
itself and that will depend on um
that will depend on the the range is
specified if you specify range 10.000
obviously it will allocate ips within
this range but also with an assignment
that you specify so it's a lower um
container
that consists of specific ap addresses
so i hope that answered your question
so let's go straight into the uh dpc
peering what is vpc peering is basically
uh vpc peering uh is a peering
connection that allows you to traffic
between two vpcs using a private ip
address so ec2 instances in either
network can communicate directly with
each other as we mentioned before you
can have multiple vpcs sitting in your
account because maybe you have uh you
have separate networks for two different
companies or two different
parts of the companies that cannot
really be on the same pc for legal
purposes or maybe they cannot share data
there is any reason available here and
um there is a physical barrier between
vpcs they cannot communicate by default
but what you can do is you can do so
called a vpc peering which means you can
actually say um create a rule that
allows two vpcs to communicate between
each other on a specific port and you
can actually have a network security
also called knuckles
uh in aws which is a network access
control list um that you can restrict
what can go through or what cannot it's
it's sometimes very handy when you have
two systems that cannot really see each
other but for some reason they must use
a specific resource or they share
specific resources between each other um
that
cannot be otherwise connected so you
basically create a ppc ring and two vpcs
can talk to each other
so
um
now default vpc deletion
if you delete a default vpc you have to
contact aws support to get it to be
stored that's very important now you
as i said before
vpc it's the default vpc gets created
automatically when you actually create a
new account and
it will have as
basically a default um range of ips that
we discussed last 16 you it will have
two subnets and and it it
it's basically a good point to start but
most of the time you don't really want
to work with defaulty pc because it's
not really that helpful because you want
to really your application your system
to be more customized towards what you
want rather than what i aws gives you um
you can
modify default vpc but i would highly
encourage you to create a new one
because it will allow you to understand
how it works and it will allow you to
fully adjust every single parameter you
want um in order to to to for your
application to work correctly
so once you delete the vpc you cannot
restore it you have to call uh contact
with support and they'll be able to
restore the whole um
default pc uh for you
itself but i would encourage you not to
use default one use your own and you'll
be able to actually control everything
in a much greater detail
so uh we're gonna
jump straight to a demo now uh we'll be
creating a custom pc demonstrate how to
create a custom vpc and um and hopefully
that will give you a little bit more
idea
so in here we are on the database
console and how i got here is basically
if i'm going to go to the console home
you'll be able to see more or less what
uh you'll be able to see once you log in
and you can go to the services in the
right corner and if you're gonna choose
under the group it's gonna be under
where we have a vpc vpc vpc
networking and content delivery here you
can see that
vpc um
section now i have a question should we
also log into the same console uh or
just watch the demo it's internet to you
if you want to actually do this in the
same time feel free to do so you'll be
able to basically see exactly the same
thing um
and you can create your own vpc at the
same time so it will give you a better
feel of how to do it so feel free i can
give you a few more seconds to actually
set it up and
well while um
i will
create a new vpc
okay so to in order to create a vpc
first of all um
let me just minimize this first of all
you need to make sure that you know
which region you are and that's it
probably mistake number one that
everyone makes and reason why i'm gonna
explain now i'm gonna take the red pen
um
it's red because it's important what i'm
about to say in the corner here in the
top right corner you can see region we
are currently in by default when you're
looking for first time into your aws it
will be north virginia which is a
default and the first data center
or or a cloud data center that aws ever
released so that's a default behavior
and
make sure before you create any vpc you
choose appropriate region and that's
very important if you don't create if
you don't change the screen and you
create a vpc well you're going to create
it in the wrong region what it means if
you want your servers to be let's say in
in dublin or in in frankfurt for example
and you create one by mistake in north
virginia well guess what you have to
create it again you cannot move the pcs
like that so make sure before you even
start creating any resources that you're
in the correct
region
so to change the region what we can do
is we can click on the region itself and
we can create
and jump in the region we want i will
jump into the island because um i
because i can and i want to
and you can see that basically we have
um
okay i don't have a right to do that so
let me to just in north virginia
sorry for that i was not aware of that
so
dpc big click on the new vpc and
and you can see there is a one ppc that
is default 172
131 0
16 and that's fine what we do is we
click on the button create a ppc
we give it a tag which is basically a
name tag so for this i can
create a demo
vpc
and we can create crd block what it is
is basically ip range that we can use in
the future
so
i would say we can create anything we
want
i would say let's create 10.0.0.0
16.
now you have the two options of tenancy
default or dedicated uh majority of the
stuff you will ever do is in default it
means it's a shared resource
just because it's sure doesn't mean it's
accessible to anyone it means that it
will allow you to allocate um
a specific resources that are in the
shared environment and that's basically
99 of the resources that you ever will
spin because um that's probably the most
effective way of doing that once you
specify those tags so the name and the
crd block you can click click on yes
create and what will happen in a few
seconds and now the amazon is actually
provisioning the
request and you can see here straight
away that you have we just created demo
vpc
that's a vpc id number which you can use
in the future as a reference you can see
the state is available you can see ip
range that we specified 10.0.0 16. um
and you can see basically dhcp options
root table which is basically created by
default network acl tenancy default and
is this a default pc no it's not which
doesn't really matter at the same stage
because we can specify which resources
are basically um
um are allocated to it by default
so that was as simple as basically
creating a vpc um if you want to
basically play around with the
cidr which is ip range that you can use
in the future uh you will need to
research this a little bit more to be
able to understand which ip ranges you
want to use now it's also important to
remember that if for example you have an
on-premise current network which quite
likely you do and majority of the people
uh are using an ip range of
of one
nine
two dot one six
eight dot zero dot zero sorry for my
writing um basically what it means is
that you'll be able to control that
particular network and you can
do anything with the last two octets
without any problems and that that's
fine um
however important thing to remember if
you ever want to do a hybrid solution
that you have in your on premise this
particular ap address and then you want
to create a vpc on the on the cloud try
to avoid having exactly the same uh ip
range the reason is if you will try to
do a routine between your on-prem and
the cloud it will actually get in
conflict and and the systems will get a
little bit confused now if you're trying
to access the same system on both ends
the systems will not be able to
determine um which which server you want
to access and if two servers have the
same ips well it's it's basically uh
end up uh having an
almost duplicated ap um and
none of the systems will be able to
communicate correctly so when you when
you're aware that you have a current ip
something like this in your office
create something different you can
create something like 10.0 as we
mentioned before or you can create 10
172. anything you want and that will
allow you to actually root traffic
properly in between and avoid all those
issues
we have a few types of addresses one of
them is a private ip address what
private ip address is is basically an ip
address that is not reachable over the
internet and that's basically the
definition of private
everything every single time you can see
private that means that it's not
an internet ip address is internal iop
address that is only visible to your
network resources that's basically a
definition
obviously
aws gives you ability to have a
internal dns server that you can
basically control and allocate different
names to internal ip addresses and two
servers can actually communicate with
each other using the the names which
which um which which is exactly a great
idea when you're trying to create maybe
more flexible and dynamic environments
so
straight away we're going to jump to the
second what is a public ip address a
public ap address is reachable from the
internet you can use a public ip address
for communication between your instances
and the internet and basically that's ip
address that is allocated um to your
instances uh so they can be visible in
the internet
and they can respond to internet
requests and they can represent
themselves as
a part of the internet infrastructure
when would you use it well simple idea
for example you have
maybe a web server
and web server itself
um
can be exposed to the internet in fact
must be because let's say it's an
internet facing web server so what you
would do is you can allocate so-called a
static ap which which which in this case
in aws we call it elastic ap which can
be a little bit confusing because if you
think about elastic it doesn't really
specify static but this is how aws came
up so every single time you hear an
elastic ip address that means a static
ip that is a public ip um
allocated to your instance so let's say
we allocated this particular ap to this
instance well that's great now if you're
going to type this ip in the browser
you'll be able to directly come to this
instance itself obviously you can
allocate this uh through a dns which
means you'll be able to do
name something like a www dot
my server dot com let's say and you
point this domain to this ip and
whenever someone types this ends on this
machine directly which is basically
public ip address
so next slide
and exactly what i mentioned before what
elastic ap
is is a public uh persistent public um
it's a static slash public persistent
public ip address that is allocated to
your account and can be
associated to
to and from your instances as required
which means when you have elastic ip
address you basically request it and i
can show you how to do it uh straight
away as well
you basically
you basically go to
uh elastic ips
and in here you can see that you can
allocate uip
and it says well basically allocate
it's thinking a little bit and once it's
done it allocated that is
a static
ip address that is internet facing and
you can take this ap address and you can
allocate it to any resource you want so
you can actually allocate it to maybe
one instance and then when this instance
is there then you have a new one you can
allocate it to another one so you can
take this ap address and mark it to a
resource that you want
so that's a that's a that's a very good
thing about the aws and elastic ap so if
for example in this
sorry i'll just go back
if in this case for example this
particular server dies well guess what
it doesn't really matter you can take
this ip address you can allocate it to
this machine and this machine will be
able to be visible from the internet
exactly the same way as the other one
was so that's elastic ip address
um
i have a question here as you mentioned
ips are not stable if we slash aws
vendor we put any hardware device which
means there are ip changes
will changes
impact a web server
um they can
one of the situations when this can
happen is when the the hardware
underneath your your instance is let's
say faulty and when you restart your
instance um it will be relocated to
another host so physical server running
somewhere else
in this case it can change the internal
ip address which is basically the
default one that aw gives you which is
this one but if you have elastic ap
allocated to the server which is this
this will never change that ip once it's
uh assigned to you it will become
persistent forever up until you release
it which means once you have it allocate
it to any machine and network ip is the
one that you showed with the internet
not the internal one so that's
that's basically that's basically the
the
answer
i have another question here if the
hardware slash instance goes down will
the name of the machine also uh will
also got replicated into new hardware
now it's entirely up to you by default
it won't the reason is
when you allocate new resource so
basically a new
new server
the server will just get ip address but
what you can do is
you can create a script that on on
launching this instance can for example
uh connect to the dns and assign itself
uh to any hostname you want so you can
you can call it maybe
d0 1 which means
this one can actually have internal ip
address so if this one fails and you
spin up another one well guess what this
one can have exactly the same cost name
with exception it will update the record
and update to this which means the ipa
itself can be treated almost as a
dynamic ap but the hostname itself
is the one that is persistent because it
sits in the dns and what dns translates
into later on it's entirely up to you
and
it's an entirely which server you're
gonna use so that's that's the idea
um so we have to code the answer is um
the the answer is yes and no because i'm
gonna give you an example that you don't
really need to even think of the ip
addresses um the reason why i'm giving
you all those ideas of service right now
is one of the ways that can be done but
not many people do
the reason is most of the time you will
use
l b in front which is elastic load
balancer and then you will have
instances behind and when you have that
you don't care about the ip address of
the of the server itself you don't care
about the hostname even that's
irrelevant because elb itself connects
directly to the instance on the almost
hardware level and the roots the traffic
directly there so you don't ever need to
specify any um any hostname any ip on
the eob all you need to do is basically
attach instance and that's all it is
which means we don't care about ap we
don't care about the host names we don't
even care about that
um you might have a situation that you
you do because you don't have eob in
your in your environment and you have a
single server facing the internet let's
say and then you you have to allocate
the server with the static ap address
which is basically an elastic ap here
and then the server will be able to face
internet which is fine but most of the
time we will do it this way because it's
a much more secure and also if one
server fails you have a redundancy
behind or even flexibility to add extra
resources and nothing in front will
change which is exactly what we want
this can be tricky as oracle dps
connect using either hostname or virtual
ips slash physical ips that's correct um
that's pretty much
pretty much what it is and what i would
encourage you when you use oracle itself
is to use basically a host names which
then translate into the ips
on the internal dns this way when you
spin up a new server it can basically
get a dns name entry and then basically
you can refer to the server on the call
on the hostname level um so you never
have ever have to specify the ips which
which is an old-fashioned uh data center
way of doing that when everything is
static
if you want aws to be pretty much very
static you can do this honestly you can
um i've seen lots of environments doing
this and the reason one of the reasons
you would want to do this is because
your application is maybe old or um you
have a very old legacy systems that do
not respond well to any dynamic um setup
and i've seen this so many times um i've
seen systems maybe like 20 years old and
the only thing they they can use is the
basic ip address not even hostname which
which which is obviously a little bit
old and it's out of date but guess what
it must be migrated because someone said
so and in this case you will have you
have to allocate those uh ip addresses
make them static on purpose so basically
jump on on the os itself and say hey you
know what this server i want you to be
this and every single time you reboot or
anything happens you always will be that
and you can do this absolutely fine
but if you're designing a new
application and you want this to be more
robust and dynamic and
and more cloud friendly basically you
make sure that you don't tie to ip you
either type to a hostname or you put
everything behind elb because you're
trying to get rid of single point of
failure which basically ip is
so
um
i can see another question here so uh
say if application hosted in the
instance uh and i want to connect with
the db service if i
get changed next time how the
communication will happen so i presume
that this question is if i hold the db
on on the on the server how to make sure
that the ap is always the same well um
when you do that make sure first of all
that os has a static ap allocated to it
on the lowest level second of all make
sure you allocate a host name to it and
every single time you
um try to you're trying to connect the
database make sure you use a hostname to
connect to it which means uh you'll be
almost always i mean like 99.9 of the
time you'll be able to reach it only in
the very rare situations that the
instance for example uh failed um
because the hardware under underneath is
is is is kind of um
faulty what you need to do is basically
stop the instance start the instance and
in this case it will get a new hardware
allocated to it and because the os
requests this particular ip to be static
it will be allocated with the cip unless
there is another instance already
running within your network that has
this already there which means you're
going to have a conflict which means you
cannot do that
so yes you can you can do this but think
of aws as more dynamic environment
and try to
not rely on this dedicated piece too
much so i would like to jump a little
bit uh further with the
slides creating an elastic ap address
basically how we're going to do that
is
we're going to jump into aws we already
showed that we can locate ip address we
can basically
have a few different actions we can
allocate the new one if you want
basically allocate and click button and
boom job done we have another ip
allocated and we're going to close this
and refresh this particular screen
sorry allocate and
boom
that we just created three ip addresses
and that's as simple as this you can
allocate them uh as many as you want the
one the important thing to remember is
the ip elastic ip addresses
are kind of free and when i mean what
they're kind of free you can see the
pricing model you only really pay for
them
around maybe 10
a month if you allocated them sorry if
you generated them
but you didn't allocate them to any
resource which means you do not use them
the reason why aws does that is because
we all know that
ipv4 which is the the
internet uh facing ip range basically
run out quite a while ago and now we're
running on the very limited amount of
ips which means
aws wants to encourage you when you
request lots of ips to use them if you
don't use them they will charge you for
it just to discourage you from doing so
and that's very important so that's how
we create it we can basically delete uh
release the ip address
um
that's what we do action release address
and this address is being released and
it will be allocated to someone else so
that's simple as this so sometimes when
you allocate the addresses
and that's a funny story is that maybe
someone else was in this ip address
before and you don't know and you
allocate this you basically attach this
to your system and then you can see a
bunch of random requests coming to your
servers and you're thinking why well
simple answer is as follows somebody
else had this system before someone
released this ip address because they
didn't need it anymore but maybe there's
two records on the internet pointing to
this particular ip address and
then
it's basically reusable ip and you'll
get some requests it's very rare again
but you might get um some requests for
some other systems that other people
used before which is like basically
sometimes getting your mobile phone you
get a mobile phone with a new number
let's say and what happens you get the
mobile number allocated and maybe just
maybe you'll get a phone calls saying
hey uh sorry uh you know
i it's i i don't know this person
because it's my new number because maybe
someone just canceled their previous and
that's pretty much the same
so it's fully reusable
um
i can see a question here so what if we
create and use it uh
it won't be charged no it won't
basically ws does give you option and
the pricing is available as well aws and
la
stick ip
if you're gonna go here
and you're gonna go into the
pricing model of
about its is the pricing sorry uh not
this
price
there you go
pretty much all the pricing up to date
is available on uh sorry it's in
there you go
gp i think
no
there you go
um basically if you're gonna go into the
uh pricing of aws and you're gonna go
into
[Music]
uh delegated hosts
on demand pricing
where is it why is product details is to
pricing where was it
on demand
they change the website again
they always do that you have to scroll
all the way to the bottom of that
um
elastic api addresses
now
basically you pay
0.00 which means free for one
elastic ap associated with the running
instance which means if you do have one
and you allocated it you pay nothing you
pay
0.005 usc which means it's a less than
one cent it's a half of the cent for
every hour
once you allocated that to a running
instance now you also pay
10 us cents for every
uh single remark um basically every
single time you remap this against
another server
so basically you took it from one and
then located somewhere else you will pay
for it 10 cents for 100 uh for each
rematch
over 100 per month and basically up to
100 is free so you can remove this as
much as 100 times and you will not pay
anything now also it's worth mentioning
that those prices here are so little
that
you probably will never even notice this
on on your bill which means once you've
allocated this to a server quite likely
you will never change it unless there's
a fault which means
those charges it will probably never
apply to you which is which is which is
a good thing
so
now we're going to discuss subnets using
sound that's in vpc
what is the subnet and the definition of
it basically amazon defines um
the subnet as follows a range of ips in
your vpc you can launch aws resources
into a subnet that you select
use a public subnet for resources that
must be connected to the internet and
the private subnet for the resources
that won't connect to the internet this
is as simple as this so think of it as
follows
if those two subnets are running pretty
much in parallel what we would consider
is if i'm going to draw the square
around it we can call it a v p c it's a
container containing all the subnets and
all the resources within
and we can say that this particular
subnet for example is facing the
internet
and we can do that by using a proper um
routine tables as well as internet
gateway and that particular subnet is
only an internal subnet which means we
will not do anything to it and it will
remain only within the vpc which means
it doesn't have access
anywhere else which means it's good
because some resources that you have
must be on the internal not everything
must be facing always internet
so that's basically the definition of uh
dpc itself sorry off of subnet itself
you can have
multiple
vpcs and it's worth remembering that
when you create a vpc it will ask you
of which availability zone you want to
allocate it to which means if for
example we are in the region of maybe
dublin which i can show you this uh in a
in a second uh in fact let me just jump
and show it straight away
um sorry about that what's that there
you go
so if you're gonna go to subnets
um we shall have few default ones and
you can see that each subnet has its own
uh subnet id and it's allocated to a ppc
itself because of the part so when you
create a summit to ask you which vpc do
you want it to be allocated to and also
you have ip range uh over of of a subnet
itself you can see how many ips are
available and the most important that we
discuss now is which availability zone
you want to use this which is actually
very good because you can create in this
case obviously four subnets each summit
is in separate and az which means you
have a full redundancy which means if
three out of four goes down well guess
what you still have a one running which
actually is amazing because you can have
and create systems that allow you to be
fully uh independent and run in the
multiple data centers and that's pretty
much with one click of a button and and
that's on its own is one of the biggest
advantages of aws
and i can see a question here can a cell
not have ec2 instances with elastic ips
or can i have 100kp
plus one static ip uh into instance
itself well
um you can either have um
you can have
either of those options is possible you
can have
something only with elastic a piece you
can have a combination of some with
elastic someone with a static and you
can have a combination of all three so
elastic static and even um
even
dynamic which we
which makes it entirely up to you how
you're gonna design the system and
that's that's the beauty of it so it's
entirely up to you how you're gonna
design this
so coming back to the presentation
public and private sadness and this is
what we're going to discuss a little bit
more to understand what happens and how
it works it's entirely up to you
now in the public subnet
which means facing the internet um
you allow
internet traffic in and out
to communicate with the internet and
your resources on the public subnet and
in the private subnet
this is locked by default and you don't
allow that which means maybe you have a
specific requirements like maybe a
database server uh
db maybe you have application server
sitting behind it maybe you have some
other resources like even your files or
anything else that you want this to be
persistent on lbs but you don't want
anyone from the internet to access this
because you treat this as a you know
private uh data and you can have either
of those two options now they can
communicate with each other if you want
this but the whole point is that it's
entirely up to you if you want this to
be available to public or no and that's
exactly the difference between private
and public subnets
i can have i can see another question
here can one instance uh
can one instance has multiple ips yes it
can and you can achieve that by
assigning additional network interface
to the to the to the instance itself and
when you assign the network interface it
will be assigned with the ip address
which means you can have multiple ips
allocated to one instance and and yes
you can
so now what we're going to do is we're
going to create a subnet and we're going
to do this on the uh aws console now if
we're going to go to subnets as i showed
before so if we're in the vpc dashboard
you can go to something about here or
fire here it's entirely up to you
remember that when we created a a
demo vpc uh
we
basically created a whole vpc
16 and we can do this now in the subnets
so create a new subnet
what i'm going to do is i'm going to
let's say say
my demo
net
and i'm going to call it
um maybe one a and the reason why i'm
going to call it 1a is because i'm going
to allocate this
in a 1a read
okay one a is unavailable here so i'm
going to change it to 1b sorry 1b
so 1b
and you can see here from the drop down
on the vpc we have a three vpc is
exactly the same that we created now the
one without the name is the default one
that aws created when we created the
account and you can see two demo ones
because i created one of them and one of
you created another one in the same time
which is absolutely fine so i'm going to
choose random i'm going to choose let's
say the the one with the capital dpc
ending with the 13f in the vpcid itself
and i need to allocate crd block now
because if we're gonna scroll a little
bit down
uh stay within a second i'm just gonna
erase this
now because our vpc itself has a range
of 10.000
what i can do is i can allocate this
with a block of 10.0 dot let's say 1.0
24 that means that it's a small portion
of slash 16 summit that we deployed
before
and if i do that and create
it's thinking thinking thinking
provisioning new subnet
and boom we just created a new sub that
name uh the demo subnet 1b there is a
subnet id generated by aws by default
you can see that the dpc that we
allocated this is exactly the one that
we chose you can see that the ip range
is exactly 10.00
10.0.1.0.24. you can see that in this
configuration we have 251 ips available
which in theory means we can allocate
251 servers within um but if you have a
service that you want multiple ips
obviously less in this particular case
you can see that we chose u.s east 1b
exactly the same that we allocated and a
bunch of other stuff that uh we
um
chose so basically this is how you
create a subnet we can create more if
you want to but there's no point because
every other one is exactly the same uh
it's important to actually mention that
when you create a subnet um on the aws
cloud it's highly recommended uh to
create at least two subnets and in two
different azs why would you want to do
this simple if one ac goes down if one
data center has a problem well you have
two other one and you can split your
resources between two different um as
which means you can have let's say two
web servers in one easy to web service
another and you are fully redundancy
covered which means if there is a fault
issue or any any particular problem well
guess what you have redundancy in a
second data center which is which is
awesome out of the box with few clicks
you suddenly harvest harvesting and
using all those data centers that you
can think of so
that's basically how you create that
so we're going to go straight into the
internet gateways what it is and why do
we use it
uh i have a question here aws does copy
does keep a copy of the data in remote
vision for redundancy is it the same for
the vpc
um
the the answer to this a simple answer
is no
vpc itself is basically
your network setup um and topology of
everything before you even
create any resource resources within and
um aws doesn't provide a redundancy for
ppc itself so if you create a vpc in one
region um
and then this particular thing goes down
well you don't have a copy of it
somewhere else by default you need to
create the the the vpc um in maybe a
fold uh tolerance um version or maybe
you want to have a dr site somewhere and
in case something goes wrong you
basically deploy resources to the the
same ppc somewhere else um as probably
we will discuss in the future sessions
you can create so-called cloud formation
templates which allows you to specify
the ppc uh pretty much everything you
can think of and basically it's a single
file it's a it's a it's a json file that
will allow you to
have to be uploaded to aws and when you
click execute it basically creates all
the resources for you automatically
which means you can have a single um
cloud formation template and you can
deploy the same template in any region
you want and
just so everything looks exactly the
same and that's the biggest benefit so
you need to do it by by
by
by hand which is which is the um
the whole point
so uh i want to
go straight into the gateways if
possible um
what is in the gateway amazon definition
of any other gateway is an internet
gateway is a horizontally scaled
redundant and highly available this vpc
component that allows communication
between instances and your vpc to the
internet
is it it is therefore sorry it therefore
imposes no availability risks or
bandwidth constraints on your network
traffic
so when you think of an internet gateway
think of it as your internet router that
you have in your house in your office or
anything else
and
you have a bunch of maybe service
computers sitting behind it and all
those computers sitting behind can
communicate with each other because
they're part of the same network but
suddenly one computer wants for example
to communicate with the internet because
you
maybe want to access the website and
when this happens it will go exactly to
the looter in this case internet gateway
and it will go to the internet um as
the rest so basically when you think of
internet gateway is it is a service that
is provided by aws which is a fully
scaled scaled redundant and highly
available and to be honest i'm working
with um
oh is the voice
better now
i i get i have i have um
complains that there is something wrong
with the voice
so omkar can you can you hear me
correctly now
oh okay great so sorry for that uh maybe
some sort of internet bleep again so uh
basically internet gateway is like your
internet router it allows you to go um
through the internet and access the
resources outside if you do not have
internet gateway you will not be able to
use the internet outside of aws which
can be a little bit problematic
especially when you're trying to access
external resources like even your office
which you must use basically uh internet
gateway for for that so
uh
let's
let's skip straight away into the next
one
and that's basically internet gateway
diagram
basically
basically it works in the way that when
you have a vpc
and that's the internet itself you
create a service called internet gateway
that sits on the vpc level and that
allows you to be allocated to any uh
um basically subnet and root traffic
through it if you need to access
internet most of the time you do so yes
you you'll be able to to do that
in this case for example because this is
a private subnet and this is a
this is a private and this is public
that means that in this case we do not
want this particular network to access
internet which means we will not grant
that in this case we only allow this
route here
which which is entirely up to you how to
do it
i can see another question if i create a
default ec2 instance without the ppc uh
will it not have access to open internet
incoming and outgoing with both ways um
yes
you still can
create a instance that is not using a
vpc i would highly
recommend not to do this and the reason
behind it is
um
it was
creating everything within vpc is much
much more secure and it gives you much
better control of how the traffic flows
you can create a server that is faces
facing internet itself with no security
if you think about it but it wouldn't be
wise and and
it's it's a default behavior from aws
right now for the past three years as i
mentioned before that every single
resource we create is sitting behind the
dpc and once configured you don't ever
have to think about it so i highly
encourage you to use always dvc um
by standard
i have
i have another question here um
if i use
a vpc then uh using an internet gateway
required for the net access yes vpc
itself is basically a container holding
all of your resources that is only
accessible from within so every single
resource that you ever spin a spin uh
within a vpc can talk to each other and
nothing else can now internet gateway
itself is a service that you put
on the vpc and then you allow specific
routes and specific resources like uh in
this case for example there's a public
subnet to access internet itself so in
order to access internet you will need
internet gateway within vpc so the
answer is yes
so
internal gateway requirements
let me take a highlight so internal
gateway must be attached to your vpc so
that's very important you have no pc you
cannot attach internet gate very simple
as this
all instances in your subnet must have
either a public ip or elastic ip address
that's important as well
your subnet some that's root table must
point to the internet gateway and we're
going to show this how to do it in a few
seconds all network access control and
security group rules must be configured
to allow the required traffic from
and uh to and from your instance and
that's also very important
so
i'm gonna show you how to basically
create an internet gateway right now
so
we're going to go back to the vpc
dashboard in here the section is
internet gateways
and we have none
we create internet gateway
and we give it a name basically we're
gonna call it demo
uh internet gateway
sorry i like to use igb because it
stands for a internet gateway and it's a
shortcut for us to use it so most of the
time when you see igb it probably means
what i just mentioned so
create
and this
it is as simple as this you didn't have
to do anything you need to create
anything and specify anything it just
created gateway itself now when you
created this gateway you can see that
the gateway id got allocated but the
state of it is detached which means it
was not attached by default to any other
bpc's which means if you want to attach
the vpc you need to basically uh tick
the the gateway that we created attached
to vpc and then you have a drop down
with all the pieces you you have so the
one that we created is called demo vpc
itself
yes attach
and now you can see that this particular
um in this particular
internet gateway is attached to the vpc
itself which means that uh if we want
any resource within vpc right now can
access internet but to do that we need
to change uh routine tables and we quite
like you will get there in a few minutes
as it's a part of of a slide deck as
well so i see someone else created uh
internet demo internet gateway 2 which
is exactly what we want so
congratulations on that
so
root tables using root tables in
amazon ppc itself
i have another question here does this
mean that vpc can handle multiple acs
but not regions uh that's pretty much
correct now when you create a vpc the
vpc is allocated to a specific region
which i already showed before but i can
show and get it quickly if possible now
we created vpc here and we needed to
make sure that we are in the correct
region from the dropdown here which
means every single of those regions can
have
a dpc now when we go to dvc in in in
north virginia and now we go to the to
let's say ireland well you won't be able
to see it because we didn't create any
so it's basically region specific
so uh
vpc itself
can host any amount of subnets that are
um allocated to
azs
so availability zones so vpc itself is
not tied to a single one because it it's
a container for everything and then
subnets uh within
are allocated to a specific um az so one
b one c one e and so forth that's that's
basically what you need to remember
and i hope i explained that
uh
okay so root table overview
let's see a definition of amazon what it
means a group table contains a set of
rules called routes which are used to
determine where network traffic is
directed
each subnet in your vpc must be
associated with a root table
the table controls the routing for a
subnet a subnet can only be
associated with one root table and at
the time but you can associate multiple
subnets with the same root table i know
it can be a little bit confusing and
trust me uh once we actually jump in and
i'm going to show you how to do it it's
all going to become super easy and
simple
um
i have another question here from
gabhari
the total number of ip addresses in all
subnets is equal to max ip addresses
every pc can handle
i can have that's correct if you created
let's say
or 24 that means that you can vpc um let
me just maybe do here i'll explain if
for example if this is your vpc
that means that you can create and
that's basically slash uh that slash 24
sorry my mistake
that's 24.
now
if
that means you can basically uh allocate
those uh those two octets now if you
create a subnet you can create a subnet
with maybe one dot zero which is a slash
and then another subnet so that's a
subnet
subnet one and then you can create
another subnet
subnet 2 with something like a 2.0
what it means that you can have up to
254 subnets
within the vpc and once you've created
all 254
basically run out of space so it's it's
maybe sometimes worth jumping instead of
24 doing fdpc slash 16 because it
allows you to actually utilize all three
octets which means you're actually
making your life much easier especially
when you need to grow to a much bigger
size later but remember you can always
you can always create a new vpc and you
can utilize any vpc later on if you need
to
so that's also um
worth mentioning
so basically what root table is is a
bunch of entries that allow you to root
traffic between subnet and any other
route possible so that's definition
so let's
have
a
internet gateway diagram explaining how
we would stuff
now
basically we have a vpc subnet here
that's
in in a region in a single region
and we have
let's say we have
um
let's say we have a private
uh private subnet
in here
what we will do is we will create a
entry called 10.0016
and the root table is only local which
means
any traffic within this range which
pretty much means everything after this
particular zero here can communicate
with each with each other within
this particular subnet
only locally which means there is no
access to the internet hence the spot
block here
now second option we have a subnet here
which is our uh basically uh public
facing uh so internet facing one
and what happens here is we want this to
have access to the internet and what we
do is we create entry saying all the
traffic and that means internet
basically zero zero zero slash zero
i want this to access internet hence
what i do is i basically point this
to internet gateway
and that particular
route table will allow any resource
within
when it needs to
access any server outside to match this
route
and be able to route itself to the
internet itself and that's the biggest
advantage and every single time you can
create 0 000 that probably is internet
anything locally you basically restrict
to only container to keep your data in
i have few more questions here let me
just try to answer
um
let me just scroll
oh sorry let me just see there are quite
a few questions which is awesome i
really like questions
so
um
let me call it a bit more
um okay so the demo login that you are
using is it your own or a common one for
the students i tried creating my own aws
three layer account and i can create a
windows
2012 service into instance but
i uh but he gave me an error api right
instance error you're not yet authorized
please
refer to the demo example creating basic
is to instance um i will be able to show
you that in a
tomorrow's session quite likely because
tomorrow we'll be discussing everything
regarding ec2 itself uh so yes i'll be
able to give you that
another question
we have is please respond
you're using your own
that's pretty much sorry that's pretty
much the same question just copy
if both vpc subnets are private ap can
we create one root table for
communication between two vpcs uh bbc
subnets
um
so
uh if both of the business elements are
private ap can we create one root table
for communication between the bbc
summers yes yes we can and what you will
have in this case is you will have
two subnets um
and two subnets will basically have
different ip addresses something like
let's say
uh
i'm gonna just use a last two octane
something like a one dot zero another
one will be two dot zero and you
actually create a single root table
in in here basically that allow any
traffic uh
between let's say
uh
something like let me guess
something like
uh
0.1 slash
and then
2.0
24. in this case what it means is that
any instance that needs to basically
connect uh to anything from one will be
able to access to two directly and and
vice versa so yes you can create those
root tables and they can communicate
between each other but you also remember
that you need to open a network uh
security rules in between that will show
a little bit later as well
so yes you can
so
so that's pretty much that pretty much
internet gateway diagram that we just
discussed
now what we're going to do is we're
going to create a root table and how to
do this we're gonna jump straight into
the
uh aws
and we're gonna go straight into the
root table
and you can see that we have one by by
default and we have each created by
default with our vpc one is with the
capital vpc another one is with it
without and that's a normal behavior
then you have
uh when you create ftpc so to create a
new root table we click on the create
root table we give it a name i'm going
to call it a demo
rt for root table
and i'm going to
give number one and i'm going to
allocate the demo ppc
okay and we just created a a new root
table
by default the root table if you're
going to slide this slider from and
those are the tabs allocated by default
you can see that the only traffic
allowed for this particular table is the
traffic within vpc which is a default
local behavior and every single time you
create one it always will have only the
entry that matches your vpc itself which
means no matter what all this stuff
within will be able to communicate but
only locally i can see i have one
question from challenges uh
no actually sorry from uh
can you let uh can you let me know how
we can access this free demo account
sure i can basically if you go to your
simply run and you type the address
um
lms simply
you'll be able to end up in your profile
it will ask you basically for username
and password so if i'm going to sign out
and i'm going to log in
i'm going to new my credits
in here in
my courses
you'll be able to see
all the courses that you've signed up
for
and i can only sign up for away solution
architect if you click on it
in here in projects
under the lab access section
you can see aws web console and you can
for the whole entire course you can use
this to basically create resources you
want and that's given to you including
price basically free of charge uh extra
on top of that which means feel free to
jump on create any resource you want and
basically that's it make sure before you
start creating stuff you read uh this
little um
uh
basically terms and conditions what it
will allow you to do and basically for
how long the uh access will be granted
in this case it's only 90 minutes
and so forth so you'll be able to
basically um
create your own resources
i see another question is dedicated to
each or each one or should uh across i
presume that this particular one is
probably shared for the
for for for the for the course and for
everyone um because i saw i've seen some
resources being created as we as we're
doing this which means quite likely
someone else created the resource in the
same time um when i was creating one
myself so
make sure you give a little bit more
unique names uh so we don't use the same
stuff you can put your name next to it
if you want or any other thing that is
unique a little bit as well
can we do anything that we get charged
for um i don't understand the question i
think no
um the account itself is restricted to
quite likely um
a few resources most of the most of time
pretty much uh
free resources um and even if uh you can
spin up something that costs a little
bit probably that's included in your in
your in your course itself so feel free
to do that um so i want to jump in
straight into the power slide
show
i i showed you how to use it
now
devices what they are and when we use
them
so
imagine what not device is is a it's
basically a network address translation
also known as not device to enable
instances in a private subnet to connect
to internet or other aws services but
prevents the internet from initiating
connections with the instances
okay
how can i explain it in a in a simple
way imagine you have
router in your office and when you're
accessing the internet uh let me just
draw it for you
um imagine that this
uh actually no
let me make this a little bit bigger so
imagine you have a router in your office
i'm going to call it r and you have a
bunch of users
sitting behind
and each of those users have their own
pc now when you connect to the internet
which is let's say here every single
user goes to the router and despite the
fact
that every single user is in their own
computer they're using their own ips
which quite likely are internal
something 192 168 and so forth and
that's great but what this router is is
basically a device that takes your uh
internal ip address and because it's
connected to the internet it presents
its public ip address which is probably
here so something like let's say uh
208.67.xx
it doesn't really matter that is a
internet facing ap and you might be
using
dot 192.168.8 x which means every single
time you go to the internet people don't
see your internal ap they see your
public ap no matter who you are within
your business they will only see this ip
address so what it is is basically a
device that creates a nut which is um
converting your into an ip into the
public ap and that's it so what nand
device is in aws it's device that does
exactly the same in here but it only
allows traffic one way which means the
instance can request stuff from the
internet
but the internet cannot access the
instance in any way which means you
cannot root the traffic to the server uh
from internet itself what it is it's a
one-way internet device
so in the previous examples we had
internet gateway and that allows you
both ways in and out we had pretty much
uh
a private a
private subnet which means no internet
whatsoever and then we have a third
option called not device or um or a
service as well that allows only
internet to be accessed from within but
not from outside which means no
um access can be granted or servers
cannot be visible from outside yet they
can access internet so i hope that
explains uh how it more or less works
now
um
in here you can see that we have a
private subnet and we know this because
we have a padlock here and basically
this particular one has no access to the
internet because it's private and we did
not allocate any routes um to the
internet itself now we have another one
in here that we have a private subnet we
can either go through a normal internet
gateway this route that means that it
can access internet in and out or if you
want to you can create an app device
that can access internet basically um
but it can only access internet out it
cannot be internal and that's
um
and that's basically the uh the root i
can see questions here from transit can
we also use pod no we cannot that's
basically those three options are
available uh to us either no internet
whatsoever one way internet which is
basically nut or
internet gateway which is internet
pathways in and out
so
next slide
basically what is the difference between
not gateway and that device
aws provides two kinds of not services
or not instance
what my gateway is is
not gateway must be launched into a
public subnet which means that
if you if your subnet itself
is uh
public you'll be able to uh access
internet by and not gateway itself if
it's private you won't be able to do
that as simple as this
so let's go and create another gateway
ourselves
um let me just go to the console now
you can see here that we can create
another gateway
we have currently known not gateways
available so we basically create one
and in here it will ask us for which
sound that we wanna have not get before
so if we click on it we'll be able to
see all the bunch of summers that we
have created now um
for this uh the amount that i use
basically the one that i create demo
subnet 1b that is
marked to a pc with a capital vpc itself
and
we will be able
oh sorry my session expired interesting
let's see if i okay probably i need to
sign out and sign in again sorry for
that it's been exactly 90 minutes since
we since we have simply launched that so
it exactly uh expired for this to work
again
i need to go back i need to log out
i need to login
i need to go to my courses
come on come on come on aws
projects
lab
and aws console
there you go if we can go to vpc again
the changes that we made uh are probably
didn't save because we didn't submit so
if you're gonna go to nut and not
gateway again create a nut
search
this one
and then basically elastic ap that we
wanna allocate that's important now
internet gateways must have elastic ap
otherwise you won't be able to connect
to the internet because some sort of
public ap must be present if you're only
using internal ips and you have nobody
kp well you cannot have such a device so
we allocated ipv4 which is this if you
don't have anything on the list you can
always create a new ip address basically
allocate it either through this button
or you can allocate it via the elastic
api it's entirely up to you because we
have one i'm just gonna use it
and that's it your not gateway has been
created um so i can view it
basically
not gateways
you can see that the status is pending
quite likely still uh spinning up which
might take a few few seconds for
resources to be allocated but you can
see instance uh id uh of sorry not uh
gateway id which is in the new format
which is much longer than the previous
one you can see private ap address yes
it does have one um
and you can see basically interface
allocated with it
as well as which vpc is allocated and
which subnet we allocated and also when
we created it
and once it's available we will be able
to
to to start using straight away
so that's how we create
a
nut
gateway
now what i will do
i will
um
i will answer a few questions uh which i
have here on my list which i'm more than
happy to and once we answer a few
questions i'll then um we'll then call
it a break for around 50 minutes again
and after break we'll just continue
straight
into further slides so
whatnot device can we access instances
from the internet
with not device can't we access
instances from the internet uh
no uh you cannot uh the reason why is
not is a device that sits in front of
all your resources on the subnet level
and basically masks
all the uh
all the ips and everything from within
your network and only allows instances
to access the internet out it does not
allow internet to come back in
so that's important to remember
if i want to make
a mask a critical application port from
internet which is the measure uh what is
the measure for this in aws now it's a
very good environment question and it's
very common now you might have
applications that do require access to
the internet because just an example you
want to be able to do let's say windows
updates or you want to maybe do linux
updates or maybe you need to download
some applications from internet that
will allow you to uh for the application
to run correctly but you don't want
internet or anyone from the internet
access your
systems what you will do is you will
create a nut uh
gateway and your allocate is not gateway
to your subnet where the system is
sitting and
you'll be able to create a rule saying i
want zero zero zero slash zero to be
accessed to access internet through the
gateway itself but
there will be no rule in return which
means this system's within and submits
itself can access internet through that
gateway but nothing from the internet
itself can come back in any way in order
to do that you will need to then deploy
internet gateway itself which obviously
allows you traffic both ways
um
i have another question here just uh
just would like to know in which cases
we need not gateway and igb however both
uh will do a similar job yes as i
already explained uh not itself only
allows
instances from within a subject to
access internet but the other way around
an internet gateway will allow internet
access uh
to actually be able to access your
instances itself so that's the biggest
difference
um
if i want to mask ssl actual port of a
web app
okay
if you will want to mask ssl actual port
um what you can do is you can use
maybe service something like an elb in
front which means elastic cloud balancer
can uh respond to a standard cord let's
say 443 um on the ssl if you want
and then can forward on any other port
you want internally to your instance
itself which means instance itself can
run on the custom port but accelerate
the world you can actually have a normal
ssl port exposed
um
no gateway is attached to a subnet as a
whole or can it make can it be attached
to individual instance within a subnet
um what you'll do is remember one thing
when you have when you have a subnet i'm
going to draw it maybe
when you have a subnet
that's a subnet you have a bunch of
servers underneath so basically
instances
and
and the gateway itself sits on the vpc
which is uh on the one tier up and
that's where the gateway is
which means you'll be able to create a
rule in a root table saying that i want
this subnet to be able to access
internet and the root would be 0.0.0.0
to
use i g v basically this and that means
that any server from within this
particular subnet will be able
to use internet gateway and use
internet so i hope i answered your
question this way
i have another question here let me just
erase this um
so for all aws setups we'll we will
should have dpc
setup done and then i am and the rest of
the products with uh will line in
uh yes now vpc itself is a basically
a custom network that i would highly
encourage you to to deploy because it
allows you to create exactly the network
you want
now you can use a default one if you
want if you're not sure and how to train
but it's better for you to create a
custom even the same way as the default
one is done because it will show you and
it will actually allow you to train how
to do it
now
you don't need um i am users
in order to create a vpc however
it is recommended that when you're
creating vpcs you don't do this with the
root
um account which you are given when you
create the aws account itself the reason
behind it is um
the root account should be only used in
emergencies and
um and really
locked and not many people should have
access to it reason why is because it's
got four unrestricted access to even
terminate the whole account which if you
think about it if you have a big company
and the root account is available to
everyone first of all you don't know who
you can track because everyone loves it
as a root and also everyone's got
permissions and privileges that they can
even drop the whole account which is
scary because not everyone knows how to
use aws let's say in your organization
so
what we usually do with the root
we lock it off we change the password we
secure to the mfa and we basically lock
it in the safe we don't use it we create
users
that have maybe one or two users who
have a full admin which is pretty much
like a route with exception it can't
drop the account and those two users for
example can create multiple users and
remember as i said only
allow specific amounts of permissions uh
to user itself which means um you don't
by mistake grant someone permission
somewhere else that they shouldn't or
maybe they did something by mistake
so i hope i answered your question
uh another question i have what if we
don't want all the instances in the
subnets to use the nut gateway
well it's it's it's entirely up to you
how you will design your network if you
for example don't want instances in your
subnets to access the the nut gateway i
would i would what i would do i would
create two subnets one would be called
uh let's say public
another one will be called uh private
and instances that must be able to use
and not a gateway would be allocated to
one subnet and other ones would be
allocated to other so that's as simple
as this and the root table allocated to
this
uh
table will allow to use uh basically not
instance by the root table itself and
this will have a different group table
that will not allow any of that
so that's i hope i don't see a question
here
um i have another question uh
for incoming traffic do we reverse
proxy
uh for web applications
now when you have a web service for
example you quite likely will not use
not
in not in front of them and the reason
is
you
either will put a
web server in the subnet
that's a subnet
that's a web server you either put a web
server directly uh pointing to internet
gateway
by the root table
and then goes off to the internet
or
if a better way of doing that you
actually
have
e
l
b
and the instances sitting behind
will be able to access now you have two
different types of eobs you have
internal eob and you have external when
you create external one the external one
is using uh internet gateway
by default which means if you put a web
server one web server to and web server
three let's say
uh it can connect directly to the
internet and the internet can obtain uh
eob ip address without any problems and
it can load the traffic to the web
server the most common scenario is the
elb itself it's quite likely also the
most uh
solid solution as well as the most cost
efficient and the reason is
um elb itself
is extremely redundant load balancer
which actually is hosted on multiple
hardware devices and the chance that
that will fail is extremely low and it
will allow you to basically have
internet coming directly to your web
servers but still sits behind some of
the device which is exactly what you
want
but all those web servers when they're
accessing internet they must have a
specific rule in the root tables to be
able to access the nut
or
uh internet gateway
which means elb sitting in front of it
will not be able to uh be used as a
basically internet uh gateway itself
it's not used for that the instance
still will have to use one of those two
routes the only reason why we use lb is
for incoming traffic to be able to
connect to the web server itself so
that's the scenario here
for example that's probably one of the
last questions before the break for
example i have a vpc subnet in a
different az
one vpc subnet is local and other vpc
subnet also local considering uh this
scenario and i need to access the
instance from internet how the best we
can achieve the scenario
okay now
if you have a
scenario um
is this
i have a few questions is this some sort
of web um is this some sort of uh
internet-facing application that you
must
um access something like a web server or
something like a mail server or
something something that physically
needs to be connected to the internet
and that would be important for me to
know in order for me to answer your
question and i'm gonna explain why
if for example
you have
no internet access application okay
so
you have a situation you have a box here
and the whole subnet
is no
internet
right by default what you can do is you
can create a separate subnet
subnet 2
and you can treat this something that's
more of something like a
internet facing
and what you can do is you can create
maybe a single server we sometimes call
it a bastion box or a jump box or
or um any device and basically this
particular subnet will have access to
the internet
gateway and what we do is basically this
particular box can either run windows or
linux doesn't remotely depend on your on
your
requirements and you basically come from
the internet to via the internet gateway
to this particular box once you log into
this box then you can jump off this box
and go directly to the box within no
internet and
root
and basically that's a very common
solution that we call them bastion boxes
we call them jump-off boxes we call them
security boxes that they're exposed to
the internet but they're locked very
tight and they're kind of part of the
application but they're only allowed to
access this subnet on maybe specific
port like three three eight nine or
maybe port
22 for ssh so yes you can create
separate cell net with internet access
which will allow to access any resource
within your aws on specific ports so
this is how we do it
security groups
and this is where the fun will start
because you notice how we can restrict
basically
all the requests on the security group
level so what is security group a
security group acts as a virtual
firewall that controls the traffic for
one or more instances you can add rules
to each security group that allow
traffic to or from
its associated instance which means you
can control what comes in and what goes
out and on which port
on the as granular level as instance so
think of it as a
building firewall
but sitting in front of your instance
itself you can create a different rule
sets you can create different ports and
ranges
and you can allocate multiple security
groups to a single instance
so it will give you a front uh facing in
front of your instance a security layer
so that's what security group is
so
uh security to control what we uh what
we can and cannot access
our instances that reside within the vpc
itself
so this is the ppc itself
and security groups will allow you for
example to say that that particular
server in this packet subnet will not be
able to access this server because maybe
there is some sort of um
maybe there is there is no need for that
there is no access whatsoever but you
can also specify that that server can
access this one if there is a need for
it no matter what someone it is which
obviously it's a benefit it's entirely
up to you how you're going to access
the service in between how you're going
create security in between most of the
time we create that based on the ports
that are only required we don't open
everything and default behavior security
group is lock everything and then open
only ports that you need
i can see another question here
the same can be specified using a root
table right
um the answer to this is yes and no now
the root table will allow you to uh
to access uh between two subnets but
once you open the root table that means
you cannot control what ports you can
you can only allow or disallow security
groups will allow you to not only
will only allow you to open specific
ports and say i want my server number
let's say one to be able to access
server number two on the port let's say
22 which is known as ssh and that's
security group the root table only
allows access between two vpc to two
subnets let's say and you cannot specify
the port itself so that's the difference
so
going straight into this youtubes for
web servers now when we specify security
groups for web servers we can specify uh
something like a type of requested http
protocol is obviously tcp and point port
range is 80. now when we do that we can
specify that the source itself is
basically internet facing which means
anything from the internet coming on
this port will be able to access the
server and the same applies for https
for basically the same rule
um okay i have a question the difference
between not a device and not gateway
okay
that's actually pretty um simple to
explain and let me just try to draw it
for you
what's the difference between that
instance and the gateway is as follows
uh instance itself is a single
uh
ec2 instance most of the time
that is running some sort of os the
windows of linux by default aws uh
encourages encourages you to use
linux because they have a template to
build this that box
and that box uh on one end is facing the
internet and on the other end it's
facing the rest of your network it's a
single box it's a single point of
failure and it works in exactly the same
way as a gateway itself but what gateway
is is not a single instance it's a
service consisting of at least two boxes
behind
it it is invisible to you
you don't even know they exist
and basically therefore you redundant
and you treat this as a service all you
need to do is basically request one it's
being created and that's extend of you
wanting to do there's no maintenance of
the gateway itself there is no patching
there is no access because it's a
service now instead in ins and not um
device itself so in instance in this
case you need to log in and set it up it
needs to maintain you need to update you
need to make sure it's running you need
to uh
you know control the uptime
why because in case this actually both
goes down for any reason runs out of
memory or space on the drive or anything
else happens to it every single instance
behind will fail and that's the biggest
challenge
and
uh the biggest advantage is that you can
use uh gateway because it's a service
that has 99.99 of uptime this is only as
good as i mean as basically you created
and it's a still single point of failure
so that's the difference between not
gateway and not instance or device in
your question i hope i explained
so
let's keep into the next slide
security groups for database servers now
you can have a ms sql server um that is
running on the instance and in this case
you will require port 1433 to be open
obviously from the internet uh which is
absolutely fine but also for you in
order to be able to access database
server which in this case is on the ec2
obviously it's not the rds you will need
to open rdp which is the remote desktop
port which runs runs on the port 3389
and then you only allow internal traffic
to be able to access it which means once
you log on into your aws network then
you can jump onto the database server
but you do not expose the server from
the internet if you would want to do
that which is not very secure but if you
really have a need for this instead of
using 10.000 you will use 0.0.0.0
0 which means exactly the same rule is
here and you allow this particular port
which means remote desktop anywhere from
internet which is a little bit unsecured
but you might have a situation like this
um
i have a question here let's assume each
vpc subnet has different applications
and i need to create multiple security
groups um
no you don't you don't need to security
group doesn't need to be assigned to a
specific subnet because when you create
a security group and i'm gonna show you
as well how to do it your only only
thing
only thing to specify is basically a vpc
that this particular security belongs to
uh and that's it if you have a if you
have multiple vpcs then you will need to
create multiple security groups for them
but as long as everything is within one
vpc and you have let's say 10 different
subjects within you can have one
security group that you can allocate to
all those instances within each single
subnet so that's the biggest advantage
of security group
now there are few rules that you need to
remember
regarding security groups by default
security group allow all unbound traffic
which means every other port every
single port is allowed to go out but not
in and that's important to remember
security group rules are always
permissive
security groups are stateful also you
can modify the rules of a security group
at any
uh let me just minimize this
and any rules applied immediately which
means at any stage and the rules are
applied immediately
which means you can modify the rules and
within a matter of a few seconds
the
the changed rule already applies to
every single instance that this security
group set asked that's the biggest
advantage
so going straight into creating security
loop and i'm going to show you how to do
it i hope my session still is valid
so security groups what we're going to
do is create a new security group
we're going to give it a name i'm going
to call it demo security group
sorry security group and i'm gonna give
it dash actually screen group one
um
and description we have to put something
description what we're gonna do is we're
gonna call it demo
security group
and we need to allocate this into one of
the vpcs so in this case capital vpc
and with matter of seconds
there you go we just created security
group
uh it's got id it's got group name it's
allocated to a demo vpc and it's got
description now in the summary you can
basically see the same as we just see
you have inbound rules within you have
unbound rules within and you have the
tags now as we mentioned before all the
outbound rules which means outgoing from
the security loop away
are all allowed by default and in fact
every single traffic to the internet by
default is allowed on every single port
but in bound rules nothing is on the
list which means nothing is permitted by
default everything is locked and that's
important to remember
so
knowledge check if we can go through
this
which of the following statements about
security group is not true a security
group rules are always permissive b
security group are stateless c security
group
rules can be modified at any time the
security group rules are applied
immediately
waiting few more seconds
okay
i think we have
quite a few answers um
so the correct answer is bf1 was correct
security group are stateful and not
stateless congratulations next
we're gonna go to network acl also known
as knuckles as we call them
definition of aws is as follows a
network access control list
acl is an optional layer of security for
your vpc that acts as a firewall for
controlling traffic in and out
of more subnets
you might set up a network acl with
rules similar to your security group in
order to add an additional layer of
security for the vpc
so just to show you this on on the um
on the chart how you would do this is
basically we would have network security
uh rule
it
to a whole subnet
or even a whole vpc if you want to
which means all those rules apply on
a whole container rather than a single
instance now security group itself
quite likely applies to only an instance
of any resource running within
so
why why would we want to use knuckles
maybe we want to use security group or
why we want to use both well the good
idea is as follows aws gives you
controls of how you can secure your
environment most of the time
i would say security groups is more than
you need because they are pretty much
very restricted on every single box
itself but you might have requirements
from a client saying i need to make sure
that none of my resources are accessible
because we have very sensitive
information in in this case what you can
say that's great what we're going to do
is we'll deploy knuckles to say that
this particular pc does not allow any
traffic whatsoever or maybe
uh i want to restrict this particular
subnet from being accessed hence i'm
going to create a knuckle that only
allows traffic within but nothing else
which means that is on the much greater
level and security group is on the
instance itself level so that's the
biggest difference
um
basically
how it would normally work is
um
i see can i repeat the previous one
again
the difference between knuckles and
security groups sure
so
as i said before
knuckle is network acl is basically a
security group that you apply on top of
either subnet
or
vpc itself
but security group itself you apply on
the instance running within
which means you can control
access to specific ports based on the
security group
to the instance itself and allocate this
the same instance to any other
the same security group to any other
instance within
but if you want to control a whole
subnet
you will use a knuckles because it's
much easier
uh this way and control everything
within the whole subnet which means
every single resource now if you think
about it one and the other is doing
exactly the same thing yeah it's true
but one is more on the resource which is
security group is running more on the
individual
servers within
and network acl controls all the traffic
within your network that you can
restrict which means if you have
multiple subnets you can control what
can access those supplements or cannot
and with a single knuckle and you don't
need to create multiple security groups
you can have both in the same time and
quite a few people are doing the same
but most of the time i've seen that
people are using only security groups
which means they leave knuckles fully
unrestricted and only control what can
go in and out via single security group
and most of the time it's sufficient
enough so that's the biggest difference
um
i have another question here security
group can be controlled uh can be
controlled traffic by blocking incoming
traffic as well yes that's correct
security group itself can block inbound
traffic and can blow a block outbound
traffic but that's pretty much allocated
to a single instance what the knuckles
is it will allocate how traffic can
behave within the network network and
subnets so
basically
uh what we have here
is we have a bunch of instances running
within
uh our are basically a subnet basically
here
and we have another one here and those
instances running security groups to
allow specific traffic within so if this
particular subnet wants to access maybe
this server wants to access this server
what would be the easiest way of doing
that would be to use security group you
would say i want this instance to be
able to access this instance on the port
let's say 22 just because we want to
and
and that's very simple you just open
this and it it's running but what if you
want to make sure that two subnets can
for example um
if
how to explain this in an easier way
if we want let's say
uh restrict internet access
uh to the subnet itself so basically
internet going through the vpc router uh
by rooting table what we can do is
create a network access control list and
say we only allow specific ip range to
access our network so imagine in a
situation you have a client that is
running a small solution data center
they have a fixed amount of ips and they
want to access your system what you will
do is you will create a network access
access list saying hey i want specific
ap so x dot x dot x dot x to be able to
access my subnet and on this level in
the security group you will be able to
then control uh even more like which
ports and which instances you want to if
if the change is global to all the
instances within the whole environment
knuckles is the way to control it if you
want to have much more granule
access like which ports and which
instances you're going to use security
groups and then that's the biggest
advantage you can have both nothings
that you don't have involved
um
i have another question here
is security like a firewall sitting on
the pc or server allowing blocking ports
from services as required yes it is it's
exactly the same thing except if it is
not sitting on the os so on top of that
it's not sitting within the server as an
application it actually sits in front of
the server um so even before the traffic
even hits your server and hits your
firewall it's already being blocked by
security group so that's the biggest
advantage
so
by default those are the default rules
we within security groups
we don't use rule numbers because that
doesn't really matter but within a
and knuckles so basically network access
list we use a rule numbers
lower the number is
higher the priority of the of the rule
is which means if we execute it first
higher the number is less important it
it is so you can see by default in here
all the inbound traffic is allowed
and all the outbound traffic is allowed
as well which which states that's
exactly uh chart
is explaining this chart
so network acl rules
each subnet
in your vpc must be associated with an
acl
so if you want your subnet to
use the
network acl you can either upgrade it to
default one or you can create your own
uh network access list
a subnet can be only associated with one
acl however an acl can be associated
with multiple subnets
that's correct
it's important to remember
one subnet
can on sorry a subnet can be associated
only with one acl
but multiple subnets can use the same
acl and that's important to remember
which means you can have the same rule
against all the subnets in your network
an acl contains a list of number rules
which are evaluated in order starting
with the lowest as i mentioned uh
there is a
there is a priority to them where zero
is the most important and
i think 500
is the least important so you're always
starting with the uh most uh important
as a zero and then you go up you can use
zero one two three four whatever or you
can jump like zero
ten
twenty it's entirely up to you from
experience i can tell you that using
maybe this particular range like 10 20
30 and so on it's a better idea because
if suddenly you need to add extra rule
you can you can always add a rule like
five in between and you're still giving
yourself uh basically nine different
options in between uh in case you forgot
some rule if you use zero one and two
and three that means you quite like you
need to rewrite all your rules just to
add one so always leave yourself a
little room in between to do that
and acls are stateless uh
responses uh to allowed inbound traffic
are subject to the rules for unbound
traffic that's important it's stateless
and that's all you need to remember
that's gonna be one of the questions on
the exam
so i'm gonna create a
basically a network acl and i'm gonna
show you some settings of it
so network basically is exactly here so
i'm gonna go straight into it and
we're gonna create a new network acl
we're gonna create a new name called
demo
and knuckles
one
and we're gonna choose the dpc with the
capital vpc itself
and
that as simple as
this and we created a new one
we have basically inbound rules by
default pretty much everything is denied
you can see action deny all the traffic
um
and
unbound rules
everything is denied as well so
basically it's a very very restricted um
rule and that rule is for the star which
means is above any other rule uh it's
the first rule to be executed which
means block everything now if you want
to allow any other uh rule within you
can what you will do is basically create
another rule we can create rule number
10 let's say
you can create maybe
tcp traffic or maybe i won't only have
access ssh or maybe better yet web so
http
and source any anywhere from internet
and action allow
and save and what that would create
is by default you can see that i block
every single traffic possible but then i
created an exclusion to this rule saying
actually
on top of that allow
port 80 to be accessed from the internet
on all inbound connection and this
packet rule that particular rule might
be used in your on your web server so uh
if you want a web server to be able to
access accept connections you basically
create rule number 80 of the source of
the internet and that's all it is
so
let's jump into the a
knowledge check as well if possible
so
which of the following statements about
network acl is not true a each subnet in
your vpc must be associated with an icl
b a subnet only a
a subnet can be only associated with one
acl however
acl can be associated with multiple
subnets c
an acl contains of at least a list of
numbered rules which were evaluated in
order starting with the highest
the acl are stateless
i'm still waiting few more seconds for
for answers
okay i think i have all the answers in
so the correct answer this question is c
that's correct
now the reason why it's correct is
because
the order that acls are actually
executed or evaluated in this case is
the high at the lowest to the highest
which means lower the number is more
important the rule is
so that was a tricky question because it
was the highest in here majority of you
answered correctly so congratulations on
that
now we're going to go to the vpc best
practices what actually aws recommends
as a solution
now a default network acl is configured
to allow all traffic to flow in and out
subnets with
which is associated
uh use private subnets to secure
resources that do not need to be
available from the internet such as a
database service
so let me explain this
basically
um as you s as you as you probably uh
seen already on
in here
uh the traffic that is being restricted
is the traffic
that is from the internet itself
um so traffic from within your subnets
in and out is allowed by default which
is pretty much a correct behavior
so going back to the thing uh to the
presentation
use a private subnets to secure
resources that you don't need to be
available from the internet such as
database servers
every single time
you have a system solution application
anything like this that uh doesn't
require direct access from the internet
you always treat it as a private
which means uh you don't allow traffic
from outside to access your service
because there's no point or need for
that
and that's important always use private
service whenever you can unless
application must be accessed from the
internet hence you're gonna use a public
one and that's important
uh next one use a nut gateway over nut
instances to provide secure
internet access to your private subnets
as we already explained because uh i had
this question already a gateway itself
has an advantage over that instance or
instances itself because it's not a
single point of failure it actually
consists of a fully monitored service
that is a
much higher uptime and also it's much
easier so i would always
advise to use not gateways because it's
much simpler for you guys you need to
spend time managing that instances
itself
next one
amazon dpc can contain anywhere between
16 and 65 000 ip addresses that's a fact
depending on how big dpc um some that
you sorry uh ip into your arcade you can
have anywhere from 16 all the way to 65
000. if you need more than 65 000 it's
better to split this into many smaller
chunks and have multiple vpcs
create a separate vpc
for deployment staging and production
environment
and that's very important if you have a
multiple
environment um you can either create
multiple vpcs for it so they're all
gonna have their own little containers
and they don't speak between each other
unless you obviously do a vpc peering if
you need to or even better idea that is
actually used more and more is to create
a separate accounts for different uh
environments like i've seen accounts for
development i've seen accounts for
staging and i even see a few for
production which means you need a
totally different set of credentials to
access all of those environments isn't
that up to you but you can use vpc to
logically uh split the different
environments rather than put everything
in one basket
now
create one amazon vpc with the separate
subnets
that is exactly what we mentioned you
can use the default one but aws highly
encourages you to create your own that
actually suits your needs the best i'm
not saying the default one is wrong
because it's not but quite like the
application will have will need some
sort of dedicated and tailored network
that only you can understand and quite
likely will not match whatever that aws
gives you hence create your own
now few
aws limits and and try to remember those
because they quite likely will be on the
exam so by default you can have five
vpcs per region and you can have more uh
if you need to but you will have to
request this from aws itself via the
request and they will be able to give
you more you can have 200 subnets per
dpc so
it's a quite big number and
um
if you need more
quite likely you will need to deploy
another vpc
you can have 200 root tables per vpc so
uh make sure you use um pretty much
um reuse the root tables rather than
create hundreds with the same entries um
lower the number of root tables it's
going to be easier for you to later on
understand and actually read your
account because i've seen that some some
people created every single table for
pretty much for every single thing out
there and it was almost impossible to
read how everything works it was a right
mess
you can have up to 500 security groups
per vpc now that's a big number and
basically
vpc itself
you can have up to five which means you
can have up to 25 000 security groups
which is a huge number
there are 50 in and out bound
rules per vpc
and that's in knuckles basically
knuckles will allow you to create 50
entries
which means it's 10 times less than
security group hence i encourage you to
use security groups more because in some
cases and i had this very often
we had a web application that
specifically needed to sit behind a web
application firewall and the web
application firewall itself was actually
outsourced to another company sitting
somewhere else uh something even like
akamai you might have have heard about
it so how is how is this working it's
basically working as follows you have an
internet and basically you have akamai
uh systems and whenever someone is
accessing a website they always go
through akamai systems and only akamai
systems are available
for uh for the whoever is using the
website to see but then akamai systems
connect to you and aws
and what happened was akamai systems
have had
more than i think four or five hundred
aps globally that we needed to wipe this
and guess what we we couldn't use
knuckles because they had so many ips we
needed to use security groups in order
to be able to whitelist them for them to
be able to access our systems and there
are some limitations to that so a
security group might be even better than
knuckles but inside and talk up to you
how you're going to use it
another one some rules can be increased
by raising tickets to aws support as i
mentioned you can have more than five
and you just need to request more from
aws via the ticket and they're quite
happy for you to do that um but just
they just want to make sure that you do
not use it um out of a default because
as i said before
hackers were very happy with using nws
at the beginning and basically spinning
lots of instances and attacking with the
ddos so aws introduced lots of
restrictions and you still need to
request this it's still possible but you
must create a ticket and you must give a
good enough reason if they if they think
the reason is stupid or it's not valid
they will actually question further
they're happy to give you that out of
the box but they still need a good
reason so that's
one of the things
now use security groups
uh for
whitelist and the network acl to
blacklist which is important now what
would you do is uh as i said before um
security group treat as a basically a
list of what you are uh whitelisting and
basically network acl you use what to
blacklist so what to block and that's
basically a very good approach here
another one create a different security
groups for different tiers of your
infrastructure architecture inside of
the vpc that's exactly what would do if
for example you have maybe a web server
and a web server quite like this one in
your port 80
out of the default maybe even 443 if you
have a ssl so what you would do
i would create a single security group
called a security group web maybe and i
would allow those supports uh to be
accessed if i want maybe from the
internet maybe through other source uh
zero zero zero zero zero zero slash zero
and if i have ten servers that's
absolutely fine because i would use
exactly the same uh rule across all of
them why because if i need to change
something like maybe allow different
report as well a single change to the
port here will allow a change to every
single service which means the whole
application
i open only one rule and the application
across every single server is open in
the same time you don't need to jump on
the boxes you don't need to change
firewall settings you actually change it
in one place so it's actually very good
um so another another another one sorry
uh here yes
if you create amazon fba security groups
for each and every tier service separate
it will it will be easier to open a port
to particular service as i just
explained and mentioned
following a security group naming
convention inside aws vpc will improve
operation management for large-scale
deployments inside epc and also it
avoids manual
errors leaks and
saves cost and time and that's very
important now listen guys when you
deploy security groups and you're
working in the shared environment
between multiple people it is important
that you can actually
describe in the naming convention um
what is this about for example you can
call it a web server and you can also
put a name of the application within the
name and it will be easy to understand
and see and if you have all the security
groups within as i'm gonna show you
right now um in here if you have a bunch
of uh security groups like here which
all of them have no name in fact not
even description
it's gonna be difficult to understand
what this is you need to go to each
single of them and then you need to go
to inbound and unbound and understand
what is actually going on and that's not
very good however if you create a
a new security group that actually is a
name and description it defines it says
uh let's say maybe um
remote desktop for
i don't know for
my my application x
and so basically rdp
application x straight away you
understand that this is rdp and it's
using application x in the description
you can actually define even more you
can say this rule is using remote
desktop services for this application
and anything you want so that would be
very very good
i have a question here if i have
multiple database servers in the
different vpc subnet uh can i uh create
one security to access all the instances
to allow the traffic yes you can and
that's exactly it create a single
security group in fact i'm gonna
basically as i showed you before we
create a single security group and what
we do is we will just edit the rule and
say hey you know what i want this to use
board and maybe
my
and
source let's say
anything
sorry i forgot about zero here
i'm not not zero
and
basically what we just done here if i'm
gonna save this
what we just done here we allowed uh my
simple port which is 1433 to be accessed
from the internet
to the security group and now if i
assign the security group to any
instance that is running database by
default
it will be opened and that's simple as
this so you don't need to jump on the
boxes physically and change security in
fact most of the time we don't even use
any firewall on top of the boxes because
we have so many tiers and layers of
security in front and that would be
really not beneficial because imagine
you actually have a fleet of 500 web
servers just as an idea and you need to
add a new ip address because something
was white listed like even the akamai
you know front and
applications uh firewall
guess what do you really want to go to
all 500 servers manually or even if you
scripted it
and change a single entry well i
wouldn't i would probably spend the
whole day and i'll probably get a few
hours i'll just give up
all i want to do is basically go here
and change a single entry that applies
to every single server that has this
security associated with or allocated
and that's simple as this single change
a whole a whole amount of servers are
changed
i have another question but we allowed
for the instance to access 1433 but my
scenario is i have a six web service
located in six dpc subnets um
do you have six separate vpcs or you
have a six subnets within a single bbc
that's important
um
to answer because if you have a single
bbc as i thought and you have six
subnets it doesn't really matter because
single security group
is actually applying to every single
resource within a vpc so you don't need
six security groups you need only one
security group and you can allocate it
against every single instance within all
those six subnets it doesn't matter
so that's the biggest advantage single
security group applies to the whole vpc
but if you have a second vpc then you
won't be able to see the security group
because it's only uh assigned to a
single vpc that you all that's what you
need to remember
so
proper naming as i mentioned before
spaniard amazon vpcs across multiple
subnets in multiple ac's inside a region
this helps in architecting highly
available uh
high and already inside your aw dpc as i
said before
and i'm going to repeat this problem
many many times after when you create
your subnet each subnet is allocated to
one
availability zone and within one
dimension you might have at least two in
case of us you actually have five
different ones in in case of dublin you
have actually three which means i would
highly encourage you to have at least
minimum two because that will give you a
high availability across your
application but if you want to use even
more that's even better because you'll
be able to spread your resources across
more data centers hence um impact or any
issue of one data center will not cause
your application to fail which is
exactly this particular point
uh and now a little bit more about cost
now if you create a hardware vpn
connection to your vpc using hardware
virtual private gateway you are charged
for
each vpn connection hour that your vpn
connection is provisioned and available
so if you have a uh if you have aws
resource here and you have a need to
supply your uh different
different um data centers on-prem or
anything like this with connectivity or
extent connected to aws
a vpn and when you do that you are being
charged for uh every single of those
connections per hour you can check the
prices on any of this website uh those
prices occasionally change most of the
time they actually get cheaper and
cheaper in fact aws i think dropped the
prices um of over 70 different times
over the past two years and it's very
rare that they increase the price in
fact i don't even remember they even
doing that
they usually
reduce the price for service because
it's actually much more available and
it's cheaper for them to also use more
um
use when they have more people
so
um
i have another question here as you
mentioned when i have a multiple vpcs we
can't use a single uh use security group
to control access am i right uh yes and
no what happens is when you create a
security group a single security group
which is basically a container of rules
that are ports are allowed in and out
you have to specify which vpc you want
to allocate this with which means if you
have a multiple of them and you create
only one that specific security group is
allocated only to a specific dpc which
means if you switch to other you won't
be able to use or see security group
that you actually created for other
which means you need to create the same
security group for the other pc in
separate that's the whole point of vpc
to be able to create fully uh
you know
fenced off
and inaccessible environments
now if you create another gateway in
your ppc you are charged for each nav
gateway hour that uh your nut gateway is
actually running and that's important
now not gateway uh itself
because it's a service it spins 24 7. uh
you can install you cannot stop it you
have to decommission it and you pay per
hour but the costs are so low that it
really doesn't matter you can actually
have a few of them and you probably
won't even notice this on your bill so
if you want feel free to see on the
amazon latest pricing page how much
there are
now uh a practice assignment designing
and a custom vpc
so today we have a simple scenario
using the concept to learn in this
lesson create your custom vpc as shown
in the demonstration now i want you to
create dbc name simply then underscore
vpc as i want the ci
dr to be 10.00 16. i want the subnet one
public with the ip uh of uh 10
0 1 0
and i also own i want one private which
is uh 1 a 10.0
placed in in separate azs that is
important i want one internet gateway i
want a onenote gateway and i want a root
table in the public subnet
i also wanted to create a security group
uh called
simply learn underscore web server
underscore security group and i wanted
to create a second one which is here and
that's pretty much it um i think it's
fairly simple um
thing to do um and i don't think we
should have any problems today we
created quite a few and and that's good
so
i would say that's your that's your uh
task to to do and what i want to do is
if you few
key takeaways as well as at the end
we're going to have a quick quiz
basically to recap everything we've done
today
basically
um
i have another question here before i
start going through
takeaways
one more thing which i'm not
understanding when we are uh
when we are security groups we are
specifying to allow access from zero
zero zero if in this case uh how we are
controlling the access to only specific
database servers well it's actually very
simple i can show you this straight away
as well
so imagine that we want to create
security group right and
oh my goodness session expired again
nice good timing
so i need to sign out
sorry for that
we've been basically talking so much
that our session sessions are expiring
so log in
my courses
architect projects
lab
console
good
so if you're gonna go to dbc
we have a choice when we actually create
creating security groups i'm going to
create a new one
in fact i'm going to use the current one
sorry
in inbound rules yes we can specify that
a source of the of the of the traffic uh
is ip address like zero zero zero which
means internet but what we also can
specify
is if i'm gonna another rule i do not
the same point doesn't really make uh
much sense because we by this everything
is allowed i'm gonna add the same port
for the sake of the exercise
so i'm looking for myself oh let me know
any other part doesn't really matter so
what we can do here is
basically uh you can add another
security group
what it means is imagine you have a
bunch of web servers
let me just remove this
you have a
bunch of servers within the pool here
and all those web servers are using
security group
called web but then
you have also
a
bunch of database servers
called security group
d
b
well
you want
you want a web servers to be able to
access a database service but you don't
necessarily want to point one to another
you can if you want to you will have a
specified ap here
but you don't necessarily want to do
that what you will do is as follows you
allow let me just switch this off
you allow
in this case um
let me you know what let me remove this
rule
you allow
uh
database which in this case is uh let's
say
uh um
my sequel my sequel my sequel
you allow mysql
um
to security group that is running a web
server which means if i create maybe
another one here
security group
web
yes create
and in here i create command a little
bit quicker and in here i create
security
db
there you go
so we want
a
a web server
to be able to access the database server
on the port 3308 what we will do is as
follows we'll go to the
uh
a database server let's say
and edit this rule and will allow
for
mysql
to be accessed from the source of the
web
of this
and we'll just basically save what it
means
is we are allowing
this
ser this group
to be accessed by the group b78 which is
this one
to be accessed on the port 3306 which
means suddenly every single server
within
whole um every single server data does
this group will be able to access the
database server with any problem on the
tv port so not only will
uh you're allowing uh on specific ports
but also you are allowing um whole
security loops in between which means
you can suddenly start creating big
pools or servers in between and no
matter if you add the server remove it
always is a member of the same group set
which is exactly what we want is
consistency
so there you go that's that's the answer
uh to your question i have another one
assuming if i am having sql cluster with
four nodes two having in a bbc subnet
one and two uh and and and two are in
vpc subnet two now in order to for
replication i need to create one group
in a vpc subnet one and one dbc subnet
two
uh
no in this case what you need to do if
you need a replication between let me
just do it a little bit i want to maybe
visualize you have a two subnets and you
have a two databases
and what you're trying to do
is you're trying to make sure that the
replication between those is running
smooth
which is great what you will do
is you create a single security group
um
security group
that let's say if you want to use port 3
and then you allocate every single of
this instance with the security group
called maybe security guru db
and that's it and as long as all of
those instances no matter what
subnet they are in as long as they in
within a one dpc sorry yeah one vpc
itself so v p srpc
it means that no matter what server you
are archived
to the same security group it shares the
same
um rules and that's simple as this so
you can you can do that
no matter what something they're in
so i hope to answer the question
so let me go back
um so
just a few takeaways from today's
session uh and then we're gonna jump
straight to the quiz at the end of it
um
i'm sure i have another question from
chandra can you show me how the audience
is necessarily a group yes i can i will
do this at the end of the session after
the quiz is possible so
um
probably even more questions will will
will happen let me do the takeaways for
now and then i'm going to show you after
so another definition of a fbpc
which is amazon digital
private cloud enables you to launch
amazon web services resources into a
virtual network that you defined the
virtual network closely resembles a
traditional network that you operate in
your own data center with the benefit of
using scalable infrastructure of aws
another one private ap address is not
reachable over the internet it uses
it used
for communication between instances in
the same network and that's important
every single not sorry let me go back
every single time you see private ap
that means it's only within
if you see a public ap address that
means you can access it from the
internet
also elastic ap address is a basically
static
public ip address that you can allocate
in order for any
internet
resource to access your server that's
really what you need to remember
so another one
aws defines a subnet as a range of ip
addresses in your vpc you can launch aws
resources into a subnet that you select
assignment is always marked to a single
a z
you can use a public subnet for
resources that must be connected to the
internet and you can use private servers
for resources you won't need to connect
with the internet
to allow your vpc to uh to allow your
vpc the ability to connect to the
internet you need to attach the internet
gateway
you can only attach one internal gateway
per vpc so internal gateway as we
mentioned before it's a single basically
a root or router that allows you to
access the internet and you only need
one for the whole entire vpc that's as
simple as this
and root table determines the network
traffic is how the the project is
directed it does not
it does this by defining a set of rules
as we said as we said before
every subnet has to be associated with a
root table and the subnet can only be
associated with one root table however
multiple subnets can be associated with
the same subnet
and one of the last ones is you can use
the math device to enable instances in a
private subnet to connect to the
internet or other aws services however
it will prevent the internet from
initiating connections within instances
so basically as you remember you either
use um you either use internet gateway
and that way you have traffic in and out
from the internet to internet you can
use a nut device and that only allows
outgoing traffic so from within your
network out
and if you have a private subnet with no
device it will only allow local
traffic that's basically it what you
need to remember
a security group acts as a virtual
firewall that controls the traffic for
one or more instances
you add rules to its security group that
allows traffic
to or from its associated instances
a network access control list is
optional layer of security for your vpc
that act as a firewall for controlling
traffic in and out of more
one or more subnets so as we discussed
this before when you need to control
traffic on the on the on the instance
level so basically on the server level
you would quite likely use
sorry you will quite likely use security
group which is much much easier if you
need to control the whole layer of the
subnet you will use a network access
control list
but it is as aws says itself optional
it's not uh it's not um it's not a must
most of the time you will need security
group to control access but this is
optional so think about uh if you want
to deploy it or not um it's entirely up
to you and up to your application
um
i have another question here
second last bullet multiple subnets can
be associated with the
uh
multiple subnets can be associated with
a single
subnet looks wrong in the previous one
every subnet has to be associated with a
root table
that is correct so far and the subnet
can only be associated with one root
uh
table of multiple subnets
can be associated with this okay yes
that's that's a typo that's absolutely
right it should be associated with the
table
that's correct
uh
you're absolutely right
i will i will find it and i will make
them change that sorry for that
um
sequence from and out should be a ppc
aclu security
gateway correct or if i'm wrong um
okay so we have a question here what
would be the correct sequence from
outside world to inside of your network
so basically implants to all the way to
inside of your network i would say
yes it's pretty much vpc first because
it goes to the layer of vpc then it
reaches the acl which is the the highest
level of security you can have regarding
the the widest
uh on the network level and then you
will go straight into security groups
which is more gradual assigned to
instances itself that's correct
um
yes i have another question of what is
the significant significance of acl rule
number
okay it's pretty straightforward imagine
that zero is the most important number
out there and 500 is the least important
so higher you get the more important the
number and the the the the rule is which
means if we have a rule zero that means
it's a first rule that will get executed
what it means is well imagine you for
example have a rule that you want to
i'm gonna go here i'm gonna actually
try to
explain it you have a rule that is
allowing let's say a whole range of ips
to access your network so imagine you
have a rule saying 10.0.1.0
24 to be able to access your your
network so basically to access your
resources local
but suddenly you have another rule uh
someone
um
came to you and say hey actually you
know what
i have a single mp address in this pool
that cannot access your local resources
because and some valid reason here what
you would do is let's say this rule is
number 10 and what you would do is you
would then specify that
rule number five for example is
10.0.1 dot let's say 100
slash 32 sorry 32 in this case it's a
single ap address in the pool uh cannot
access local
which means this rule is much much
higher than this one which means uh
those two rules if you think about it
they
they kind of contradict each other a
little bit because you're allowing
everything and that's that's basically
accept and that one is decline
decline so what happens is with this
rule number five you actually decline
access
and then with this rule later on you
allow access but because this rule is
not a higher number that takes priority
which means the port sorry ip10
100 in this case is still blocked that's
the significance of a rule number if you
would put this other way around what
would happen is yeah you would block
this
and let's say if you locate the number
15 to this you would block number 100
from the accessing local resources but
rule number 10 which is higher would
actually open this again and would
overwrite your previous rule so that's
important how you use those numbers
so i hope i explained that
to you
sorry let me just remove
this
as i mentioned before security groups
are acts as a fire virtual firewall that
controls the traffic for one or more
instances
you